in our series Vlad to Dad we help our
very own Vlad gutier prepare for
fatherhood this morning we have some
helpful how-to tips for Vlad who is
still here with us right now and
everyone else who is getting ready to be
a parent for the first time parents
editor-in-chief editor-in-chief Grace
bastidas joins us right now good morning
how are you doing hi Grace thank you for
having me all right congratulations
thank you very much I'm ready now every
parent is changing diapers Around the
Clock yes so can you give us a little
how-to to help them out yes you're
changing 10 diapers a day or more so
basically you want to put your baby on a
flat surface guys want to follow along
all right
well I think that's a dirty diaper
any clothing rompers with Snaps are
really good to get diaper axes lift your
baby up gently put the clean diaper
that's a good tip because you want to
avoid messes right all right so then
remove the soil diaper clean up quickly
get your
[Music]
[Laughter]
a little bit I mean it dries really
quick and then you put the new diaper
over their belly and you fasten the tabs
let me see what you're doing all right
you got to get in and out especially in
the middle of the night yeah well I
started late bam there we go
look at that wait but hold on I do have
some experience can I just show that
picture of me this is me back in the day
with my little nephew who's now 18 years
old oh okay changing his diaper my
little brother I was 16 when he was born
was his primary babysitter for many
years know how to do this the only thing
that's different is this technology for
diapers has changed back in my brother's
day it was cloth can you imagine
impressive you can still use cloth now
okay so I have a question for you this
is a dividing debate in my house do you
take out the wings when you put it on
the baby or do you let it do you tuck it
in oh that's a good question you can
take out the wings I mean I think it's a
question of preference but take out the
wings also if your baby has their
umbilical cord you can you can fold roll
this down a little front yeah okay okay
so let's get to swaddles because that's
something else that probably has changed
yes swaddles are new our new Fango thing
okay okay all right so for swaddling
swaddling is really great because it
gives babies a sense of security by
reminding them of the warm and it also
helps them sleep better which in turn
will help you okay I'm down for that so
you want to lay your baby on their back
and the blanket should be in the shape
of a diamond their head and neck above
the fold arms tucked in all right you
want to tuck in the left arm oh the left
arm I'll show you really quick oh look
Adriana's already done
oh mama Hello mama let me all right so
what do we do I start over start over
Okay okay let's start okay so we have
the left arm out you want to keep the
left arm out okay so you're gonna follow
me all right so think of the swaddle as
hands on a clock okay start with the
nine o'clock hand and move it across
your baby's body under her backside
leaving the other arm exposed make sure
you get those little shoulders okay and
you want to tuck in tightly they should
be snug not squeezed in then you take
the tail which is a six o'clock hand and
you tuck that on the top okay then get
that little oh boy no Vlog what a little
loose all right but it's a little loose
let's keep going let's keep going so let
me take the 3 P.M and roll that on top
of your baby's belly the back side lift
up your baby gently well we're gonna
have we're gonna need extra quiet Tony
glad you have a night nurse and then
tuck it under the chin I think we're
going to need to stay after school
and practice it some more what so no
biggest tips Lay Your Baby on their back
for safety to sleep there should be
nothing in the crib or bassinet and the
American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends to stop swaddling once they
show signs of rolling over all right you
got it the control room is totally
making fun of me
all right please please show them show
them all right uh all right so let's
talk about something that I can work on
very easily diaper bags yes so we love a
sleek and simple diaper bag this is a 7
A.M BK 718 backpack and it's lightweight
I think I have this girl I think I have
this nice yeah it's got loads of
compartments it's got stroller straps
for you know when you're on the go and
this is the kibu fanny pack it has a
waterproof pocket for wipes this I see
you with this any detachable changing
mat so so you may be tempted to take
your whole Nursery with you when you go
out but all you need are the diapers the
wipes the rash cream a change of clothes
in case of accidents you know what I'm
talking about and a burp cloth to soak
up drool and also this one doubles as a
bib and it's from Aiden and anaisin it's
really I love it all right let's talk
about I mean he's ready he's ready
I'm gonna put this right here here we go
we've got mine oh we're mine's like this
all right all right and then this this
car seat thing is going to be probably
I'm actually on rehearsal for real this
week learning how to put the car seat in
a car great great so you have we're
giving you a heads up here okay
um so the car seat you want the baby to
be safe so they should be in the back
seat and rear-facing that's the most
important thing read the instruction
manual so that you know it's properly
installed it shouldn't be loose on the
base and it should be correctly angled
so that your baby's head does not flop
forward and once your baby's in there
you want to tighten the harness so that
it's snug and this chest clip should be
in the center of her chest in line with
the armpits and you can do a little test
it's called The Pinch test and if you
can pinch any of this between your
fingers it's too loose so you need to
tighten it some more all right this is
from Britax and it's got side impact
protection and they will actually do a
car seat checkup with your virtual car
seat checkup for free so important all
right and any brand you get great all
right
you're ready I gotta get the swaddling
down I know I gotta get the swaddle I'm
almost graduating four more weeks